[Musique]
dans le quartier mile end à montréal
le café fac où se démarque avec sa
spécialité launay guérit les
travailleurs du quartier ils ont
vraiment adoptés
naomi s'est l'experte du tout petit
triangle est ce que les humains adrian
montré moins beau mais non ya pas de
triangle est permis si vous pouvez
intégrer chez elle mais c'était
pontificia l'on confiera le voudra
il a travaillé aux falcons qu'il
aujourd'hui vers le graal quo est
intenable oui mais c'est parce qu'à
chaque matin c'est elle qui cuisine elle
enfin environ 125 à 140 par jour et
depuis cinq ans on est passé de 100
milles on a arrêté de comptes à 100
millions à nice un triangle de riz avec
tient bien sûr à l'intérieur russe et
leur nourriture de riz un peu au japon
accueillis et c'est que le triangle en
soi soit le plus complet possible
légumes protéines equiterra saveurs tout
résumé un client le concept c'est que ce
soit facile à manger avec les doigts
la petite lamelles d'algues sur le nez
guéri prend alors tout son sens
le nigiri le silène cheveux très
rapidement le midi les japonais de
manche le matin en collation
c'est vraiment toute la journée leurs
élus mais est-ce que c'est du riz à
sushi oui exactement riz à sushi mélangé
avec du riz brun que ça soit vrai bon
goût la bonne technologie comment on
appellerait celui-là japonais comme ça
c'est concernant notamment à
l'échauffement préférées alors on a mis
les yeux qu'ils sont cuits dans de
l'huile de sésame la poudre d'ail sel
poivre
le falcou offre cinq saveurs chaque jour
en plus de celui aux oeufs il y a
sûrement sésame porc rôti edamame et une
saveurs nouvelles
chaque jour aujourd'hui on est guérie au
goût de riz frit cpo friis et chiite haq
est encore là une omelette qui est monté
dans un ennui le sésame les oignons van
nhon me tente de me montrer comment
façonner les eaux ni guéri en métallo un
petit peu ici
la cdc est en panne jeudi comme ça je
vais donc se rappelant que ok blanche
comme ça c'est comme ça on n'écrase pas
aux autres ce que ça vous fait rien
voilà c'était mon idée lit on y dîne
très léger c'est le mélange des goûts
c'est bon ça nous même les gens qui
aiment pas les ags je pense qu'ils me
raisonne à oui oui pas cette délicieuse
en effet juste rien ici sur mon maître
et fait le lit peut avoir seulement une
heure et demie de durée de vie pour tous
vos projets
[Musique]
la corée du sud n'a aucune raison d'être
jalouse du japon est là aussi sont rien
mais il porte un autre nom
c'était un homme d'hakim pas madame kim
est propriétaire du casse-croûte coréen
lee et jim au métro médine à mourir moi
je pense le drian
on sort de ce chien comme un format
triangulaire dedans il y a juste eu un
ingrédient spécial avec une sauce c'est
plus simple aussi c'est très facile de
prendre le king bape est plus gros et il
est recouvert entièrement d'algue nori
shelly ann kim on en fait 500 par jour
savard normes et manger à plus de
caisses différents bureaux ton maillot
et ton piquant c'est le meilleur goût
pour les clients crevettes frites poulet
rôti tofu port pican sont quelques-unes
des saveurs proposées la couleur d'une
soixantaine vinoy qui est l'acte et aux
mélanges rhinoise libéré parce qu'on ne
mange pas je serai du riz noir ça tangue
leclerc mots maintenant mon préféré est
ton cul avec jara pignon c'est tout
nouveau nouveau
faire c'est commenter ça avait un
terrier
bon appétit à acheter
[Musique]